if you and DC need a show yeah that
would be a fun podcast or something like
that yeah you know this is a sellout
s
talk to us what happened the RC and DC I
don't even want a DC so I wanted to I
wanted to show with RC DC like actually
before that show happened hit me up and
he's like look look Max uh uh ESPN is
coming to me they have a short idea you
know he was like you know people let me
talk about my business
they're opening whatever I was like bro
I'm down but I'm like I'm about to tell
them bro like I'm still fighting so like
we gotta just figure out a schedule let
me know and he's like yeah I'll let you
know it goes [__] quiet for weeks you
know I mean months boom RC DC show I'm
like okay DC I see you
[Music]
he's the worst bro he's lucky he's the
heavyweight champion something in the
world because other than that you're
nothing to me
you think you've got DC with the hands
if it's just hands brother I got him the
wrestling the eating whatever
I told DC I'll fight him in heavyweight
but people think it's a pig roast with
DC
I heard the man is like training pawns
we can fight at Super everywhere I don't
care
yeah we might have to replace RC huh no
no we replace DC
you're rcnu RC is a great guy
DC I told DC DC enjoy everything you're
having because like I want to fight
for at least like maybe six more years
five more years and I'm pushing it the
we see where where the career goes but I
told DC you only really have that to
have a career outside of fighting
because after that I'm gonna take every
single job
DC has he wants to be a garbage man
yes I'm gonna take this job I'm gonna
move there just for it what what days is
the trash guys Tuesday Thursday okay I'm
just moving in for that day I'm flying
in doing my job moving you're commuting
bro I'm gonna take busy I don't think DC
knows what's coming bro he don't you
think it's all fun and games
lose your job DC yeah
damn
bro I've never seen somebody dislike
somebody but do it in a pleasant way
it's Hawaii
I love PC that's why you know but you
got to pay
would you have gone to wherever they
shoot the show would you have like lived
out of there or worked out of there I
mean that's the hard thing so at the end
of the day I think City would have but
they don't no it's not because DC did
that's awesome yeah oh this is a fraud
bro his background is a TV that he
changes
yeah he's like calls me up like go back
so one day she didn't show your max
watch this I can change my background
look I got a gym I got a bookshelf I got
my belt so I was like DC you're a fraud
bro let me see fraud hung up the phone
dead talk to him that's all it is you
know that's your friendship with DC bro
you don't want to be friends and he's a
fraud
the only time he gets something from me
is when he needs an interview is that
right DC wow and then he gets all mad
because I reached out to him yeah and I
said I wanted to I wanted to uh come and
do some wrestling with him right yeah
and then and then he's like yeah let me
know when it comes then and then it
comes to thinking like his teammate is
Islam you know I mean and like one day
maybe I want to fight Islam so I can't
be training with the guy so he's like oh
tough with me back bro you're supposed
to come to the house we had great
training I was like brother don't fall
you'd be a spy for you bro you'd be a
spy for Islam what's going on bro you're
if is
in the show I'm pretty sure you guys
would have got him would have been DC
I don't know loyalty DC getting exposed
right now bro Full Exposure yeah DC bro
sorry would be a fight you in Islam oh
bro I would love to fight that I would
love to fight that I mean we're supposed
to fight khabib here in Brooklyn so why
not you know what happened brother that
the commission the commissions what
happened the athletic commission is what
happens what was it bro I mean you know
without saying nothing too crazy it is
what there was a at that time there was
super hard against MMA about MMA coming
over right they finally got it whatever
and then
I was freaking you know cutting weight
they didn't like the way they didn't
like the way I looked and they said nah
he don't look good okay whatever what
I'm like I mean how are you supposed to
look when you're cutting weight yeah
pretty sure you're supposed to look like
death yeah I don't know you know it's
not very body positive yeah they looked
even they're like and it doesn't help
that I'm like six feet you know yeah
that's like a skinny little kid you know
I look like at the end of the day yeah
that's with you especially when you cut
I don't see any bro yeah yeah do you
remember uh uh Antonio Morales remember
the boxer he used to fight around like
130. remember am I getting it right
Morales yeah yeah he's a he's a cheat in
fight night bro
wait the video game yeah
but he looks you guys look the same way
you're just kidding kids yeah but it
gets all boned yeah especially my cheeks
and I mean I should start modeling
That's How Strong my cheek is like
boom hit a pose is it harder to cut the
weight now that you're getting older I
mean not really actually it actually got
easier wow yeah before before I met my
wife I was just like oh because you were
you weren't dying go whatever and do
whatever now she kind of keep me easy so
it's like it's much more easier I would
say Okay walk around me I walk around
like uh maybe like around 60 65 nothing
crazy oh you stay in shape yeah I tried
to tried to because you never know when
you get a call you know what I mean
before a balloon up bro I'd be like
I I'm telling you guys when I tell you
guys bro that I like I would fight
decent heavily I'm not joking
if the money is right brother
what would it take Ally well whatever
it sounds like about 50 bucks no no no
we need money bro we need money
um five mil
oh that's a guarantee brother
I think that would be kind of
low-balling me and him so we'd probably
go higher but bro we in the meals bro DC
I love you bro but we're gonna we're
gonna fight each other yeah we can be
friends after don't be rich yeah
you just want to bulk up I think that's
what it is right you just want to eat
whatever you want oh yeah is there
anybody who wouldn't fight anybody yeah
ah no I don't know bro I'll play anyone
why not there's nobody that you're like
okay I'm terrified of this person or I
love this person so much I don't know if
I could build myself up to do it I don't
think that's a problem for him no you
can separate the two things you can like
somebody if we're all getting rich why
not you know at least get some money you
know yeah yeah like like uh like this
like this like if
I mean it's tough to say because I'm
never in the situation but if my
teammate was was the second best guy in
the world and was fighting for each
other fighting [__] it sucks you gotta
find a new place to train but bro and
then it did but we could get it on bro
we can [__] set up our both families
why not